اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من غلاف غزه اهلا
بكم 25 شهيدا في قصف اسرائيلي بدير البلح
وخان يونس ووزاره الصحه في غزه تقول ان
الاحتلال ارتكب 13 مجزره في القطاع رح
ضحيتها 107 شهداء واليونيسيف تقول ان
تصعيد القتال في رفح سيمثل تحولا مدمرا
اخر في الحرب وقد يودي بحياه الالاف مجلس
الحرب الاسرائيلي ينهي اجتماع وصف بالقاس
والمتوتر لبحث رد حماس على الاطار العام
لابرام اتفاق وبايدن يصف الرد الاسرائيلي
في غزه بانه تجاوز الحد ويقول انه يدفع
بقوه من اجل التوصل الى وقف مستدام للقتال
ويؤكد انه اقنع السيسي بعد رفضه بفتح معبر
رفح ومارس ضغوطا على نتنياهو لايصال
المساعدات والرئاسه المصريه تؤكد انها
فتحت معبر رفح منذ اللحظه الاولى دون قيود
او شروط لكن استمرار قصف اسرائيل للمعبر
حال دون ادخال المساعدات كتائب القسام
تعلن تدمير اكثر من 10000 اليه عسكريه
اسرائيليه منذ بدايه الحرب بقذائف الياسين
وتؤكد قتل واصابه عدد كبير من ضباط وجنود
الجيش الاسرائيلي ومرتزقته سرايا القدس
تقول انها تخوض اشتباكات ضاريه مع
الاحتلال غرب خان يونس وتؤكد قصفها
بالصواريخ اليات وحشو اسرائيليه شرق
المحافظه الوسطى والجيش الاسرائيلي يعلن
اصابه ثلاثه عسكريين بجروح خطيره في معارك
غزه ونقلهم الى مستشفى سوروكا تزامنا مع
اقتحامات الاحتلال لطول كرم و قلقيليه
والخليل وبيت لحم الشرطه الاسرائيليه
تعتدي على المصلين عند باب الاسباط
وتمنعهم من الوصول الى المسجد الاقصى
واصابه فلسطينيين برصاص الاحتلال في بلده
بيت فوريك شرق نابلس ونادي الاسير يقول ان
الاحتلال اعتقل منذ الليله الماضيه 15
فلسطينيا في الضفه
الغربيه الى
اللقاء